today we have Elon Musk Eon thank you
for joining us thanks having right so we
want to spend the time today talking
about your view of the future and what
people should work on so to start off
could you tell us you famously said when
you were younger there were five
problems that you thought were most
important for you to work on um if you
were 22 today what would the five
problems that you would think about
working on B well first of all is it I
think if somebody is doing something
that is useful to the rest of society I
think that's a good thing like it
doesn't have to change the world like
you know if you make something that has
high value to people and frankly even if
it's something if it's like just a
little game or you know the some
improvement in photo-sharing or
something if it if it has a small amount
of good for a large number of people
that's I mean I think that's that's fine
like stuff doesn't need to be change the
world just to be good but you know in
terms of things that I think are most
likely to affect the the future of
humanity I think AI is probably the
single biggest item in the near term
that's likely to affect humanity so it's
very important that we have the advent
of AI in a good way but that is
something that if you if you could look
into a crucible and enter the future you
would like you would like that outcome
because it is something that could go
could go wrong and as we've talked about
many times and so we really need to make
sure it goes right that's that's I think
AI working on ai and making sure it's
great future that's that's the most
important thing I think right now the
most pressing item sec then obviously I
think Institute with with genetics if
you can actually solve genetic diseases
if you can promote dementia or
Alzheimer's or something like that that
was genetic reprogramming that would be
wonderful
so I think this
genetics it might be the sort of second
most important item I think having a
high bandwidth interface to the brain
like we're currently bandwidth-limited
we have a digital tertiary self in the
form of our email capabilities like
computers phones applications we're
effectively superhuman but we're
extremely bad with constraint in that
interface between the cortex and your
sort of that the tertiary digital form
of yourself and helping solve that
bandwidth constraint would be I think
very important for the future as well so
one of the I think most common questions
I hear young people and bishops young
people ask is I want to be the next to
go musk how do I do that um obviously
the next Elon Musk will work on very
different things then than you did but
what have you done or what did you do
when you were younger that you think
sort of set you up to have a big impact
well I think this well I should say that
I do not expect to be involved in all
these things so the the the five things
that I thought about the time in college
still quite a long time ago 25 years ago
you know being you know making life
multiplanetary selling accelerating the
transition to sustainable energy the the
Internet broadly speaking and then
genetics and AI I think I didn't expect
to be involved in in all of those things
I actually at the time in college I sort
of thought helping with electrification
a bit of cars which was how we start out
and that's a that's actually what I
worked on as an intern was advanced
ultra capacitors with to see thick there
would be a breakthrough relative to
batteries for energy storage and in cars
and then when I came out to go to
Stanford that's what I was going to be
doing my grad studies on is it was
working on her best at energy storage
technologies for electric cars and I put
that on hold to start an Internet
company in 95 because that that does
seem to be like a time for particular
technologies when there
at a steep point in the inflection code
and and I didn't want to you know do a
PhD at Stanford and then and what sure
will happen and then and I wasn't
entirely certain that the technology I'd
be working on would actually succeed I
can get you can get a you know doctrine
on many things that ultimately are not
do not have a practical bearing on the
world and I wanted to you know just I
really was just trying to be useful
that's the optimization it's like what
do what can I do that would actually be
useful do you think people that want to
be useful today should get PhDs um
mostly not so what what is the best some
yes but mostly not how should someone
figure out how they can be most useful
whatever this thing is that you're
trying to create what would what would
be the utility Delta compared to the
current state-of-the-art times how many
people it would affect so that's why I
think having something that has that
that has a mix makes a big difference
but effects a sort of small to moderate
number of people is great as is
something that makes even a small
difference but but affects a vast number
of people like the area yeah on you know
under the yeah exactly the area under
the curve is would actually be roughly
similar for those two things so it's
actually really about yeah just trying
to be useful and matter when you're
trying to estimate probability of
success so you say something will be
really useful good area under the curve
I guess to use the example of SpaceX
mmm-hmm when you made the NGO decision
that you were actually going to do that
this was kind of a very crazy thing at
the time very crazy there shortly yeah
I'm not shy about saying that but I kind
of agree I agreed with them that it was
quite crazy crazy if if the objective
was to achieve the best risk adjusted
return sliding our company is insane but
that was not that was not my objective
why I I'd totally come to the conclusion
that if something didn't happen to
improve ROC technology would be stuck on
earth forever and and the big aerospace
companies had just had no interest in
radical innovation
all they wanted to do is try to make
their old technology slightly better
every year and in fact sometimes we
would actually get worse and
particularly in Rockets is pretty bad
like the in 69 we were able to go to the
moon with a Saturn 5 and then the space
shuttle could only take people to
low-earth orbit and then the Space
Shuttle retired and that trend is
basically trends to zero it feels I
think technology just automatically gets
better over year but I actually doesn't
it only gets better if smart people work
work like crazy to make it better
that's how any technology actually gets
better and by itself technology if
people don't work and it actually will
decline you can look at the history of
civilizations many civilizations and
look at say ancient Egypt were they able
to pull these incredible pyramids and
then they basically forgot how to hold
permit and and then even hieroglyphics
they forgot how to read hydrocal
hieroglyphics so we look at Rome and how
they will to look to build these
incredible roadways and aqueducts and
indoor plumbing and they forgot how to
do all of those things and there are
many such examples in history so I I
think choice bear in mind that you know
entropy is not on your side
yeah one thing I really like about you
is you are unusually fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something that's
crazy and I know a lot of pretty crazy
people you still stand out where does
that come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all I'd say I actually
think I feel
feel fair quite strongly so it's not as
though I just have the absence of fear
I've I feel it quite strongly but there
are times when something is important
enough you believe in it enough that you
do it in spite of the fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think I I I should if
you think well I feel fear about this
and therefore I shouldn't do it it's
normal to be to feel fair like you'd
have to
definitely something mentally wrong you
should feel fair so you just feel it and
let the importance of it drive you to do
it anyway yeah you know actually
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so my starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low what do you think the odds
of the Mars colony are at this point
today well um
oddly enough I actually think they're
pretty good
so like when can I go okay at this point
I am certain there is a way I'm certain
that success is one of the possible
outcomes for establishing a
self-sustaining moss colony in fact
growing lost colony I'm certain that
that is possible
whereas until maybe a few years ago I
was not sure that success was even one
of the possible outcomes it's a
meaningful number of people going to
Mars I think this is potentially
something that can be accomplished in
about 10 years
maybe sooner I mean maybe 9 years I need
to make sure that SpaceX doesn't die
between now and then and that I don't
die or if I do die that someone takes
over who will continue that you
shouldn't go on the first launch yeah
exactly like the first launch will be a
robotic anyway so I want to go except
for that internet latency yeah they were
at latency to be pretty significant I
Mars is roughly 12 light minutes from
the Sun and Earth is 8 light minutes so
closest approach Mazdas 4 light minutes
away that furthest approaches 20 a
little more because you have to you
can't sort of talk directly through the
Sun
speaking of really important problems um
AI so you have been outspoken about AI
um could you talk about what you think
the positive future for AI looks like
and how we get there okay I mean I do
want to emphasize that um this is not
really something that I advocate or this
is not prescriptive this is simply
pretty hopefully predictive as you look
so I'm Sayla well like this is something
that I want to occur instead of so this
I mean I think that probably is the best
of the available alternatives the best
of the available alternatives that I can
come up with and maybe somebody else can
come up with a better approach or better
outcome is that we achieve
democratization of AI technology meaning
that no one company or small set of
individuals has control over advanced AI
technology like that that's very
dangerous
it could also get stolen by somebody bad
you know like some evil dictator or
country could send their intelligence
agency to go steal it and gain control
it just becomes a very unstable
situation I think if you've got any any
incredibly powerful AI you just don't
know who's who's going to control that
so it's not as I think that the risk is
that the AI would develop a will of its
own right off the bat I think it's more
that's the consumers that some someone
may use it in a way that is bad or and
even if they weren't going to use in a
way that's bad but somebody could take
it from them and use it in a way that's
bad that that I think is quite a big
danger so I think we must have
democratization of AI technology make it
widely available and that's you know the
reason that obviously you mean the rest
the team you know created open AI was to
help with the democracy our a AI
technology so it doesn't get
concentrated in the hands of a few and
but then that of course that needs to be
combined with
solving the high bandwidth interface to
the cortex humans are so slow humans are
so slow yes exactly but you know we
already have a situation in our brain
where we've got the cortex and limbic
system and the limbic system is kind of
a mess that's the primitive brain it's
kind of like the your instincts and
whatnot and then the cortex is thinking
of a part of the brain those two seem to
work together quite well occasionally
your cortex and limbic system may
disagree but they attending it works
pretty generally works pretty well and
it's like rare to find someone who I've
not found someone who wishes to either
get rid of the cortex or get rid of the
Olympic system very true
yeah it's that's unusual so so I think
if we can effectively merge with AI by
improving that the neural link between
your cortex and the your digital
extension yourself which already likes
that already exists just has a bandwidth
issue and then then effectively you
become an AI human symbiote and and if
that then is widespread with anyone who
wants it can have it then we solve a
control problem as well we don't have to
worry about some sort of evil dictator
AI because kind of we are the AI
collectively that seems like the best
outcome I can think of so you've seen
other companies in the early days that
start small and get really successful um
hope I don't regret asking this on
camera but how do you think open AI is
going as a six month old company I taste
you go pretty well I think we've got a
really talented group what opening eye
and yeah really really talented team and
they're working hard
open a is structured as see a 501c3
nonprofit but you know many nonprofits
do not have a sense of urgency it's fine
they don't have to have a sense of
urgency but opening ideas
is I think people really believe in the
mission I think it's important and it's
about minimizing the risk of existential
harm in the future and so I think it's
going well I'm pretty impressed with
what people are doing in the talent
level and obviously we're always looking
for great people to join we call a
mission list of 40 people knots yes well
well alright just a few more questions
before we we wrap up how do you spend
your days now like what what do you
allocate most of your time to my time is
mostly split what's between SpaceX and
Tesla and of course I I try to spend
it's a part of every week at opening I
so I spend most I spend basically half a
day at opening I most weeks and then and
then I have some open enough that
happens during the week but other than
that it's really traceable interlaced
like so Tesla like what is your time
look like there yeah so it's a good
question um I think a lot of people
think I must spend a lot of time with
media or on business II things but
actually almost almost all my time like
80% of it is spent on engineering design
in engineering and design so it's
developing next generation product at
that's 80% of it you probably remember
this a very long time ago many many
years you took me on a tour of SpaceX
and the most impressive thing was that
you knew every detail of the rocket and
every piece of engineering that went
into it I don't think many people get
that about you
yeah I think a lot of people think I'm
kind of a business person or something
it just fine like business is fine but
um a guy it really it's you know it was
like it SpaceX Gwynne Shotwell was chief
operating officer she kind of manages
legal finance sales and kind of general
business activity and then my time is
almost entirely with the engineering
team working on improving that the
Falcon 9 and the Dragon spacecraft and
developing the most colonial
architecture I mean that Tesla
it's working on the model 3 and yes I'm
in the design studio to agree up
happening a week dealing with its
aesthetics and and look and feel things
and then most of our week is just going
through engineering of the car itself as
well as engineering of the factory
because the biggest epiphany I've had
thus this year is that what really
matters is that is the machine that
builds the machine the factory and this
that is at least towards my to eat
harder than the vehicle itself it's
amazing to watch the robots go here and
these cars just happen
yeah now this actually is has a
relatively low level of automation
compared to what the gigafactory will
have and what model 3 will have what's
the speed on the line of these cars
actually average the line is incredibly
slow it's probably about a both X and s
it's maybe a 5 you know 5 centimeters
per second and what can you go this is
very slow or what would you like to get
to I'm confident we can get to to at
least 1 meter per second so 20-fold
increase that would be very fast
yeah um at least I mean I think quite a
1 meter per second just put that in
perspective is a slow walk or a good
medium speed walk a fast walk could be 1
and 1/2 meters per second and and then
the fastest humans can run over 10
meters per second so if we're only doing
point zero five meters per second that's
very slow current current flow speed and
and at 1 meter per second you can still
walk faster than the production line